Hi! I'm Alison and this is what I wore to get my job at Rent the Runway.
When I was getting ready for my Rent the Runway interview,...
...I went on social media for Rent the Runway to see what other people were wearing,...
...and that really helped me.
I just picked something out of my closet that was really bright,...
...thinking maybe that would help them remember me,...
...and it was something I felt really comfortable in, too.
And one thing I remember is that I chose to wear my nose ring,...
...which is something I would normally take out for an interview,...
...but I was thinking to myself, these people just need to accept me,...
...and if they do, then I know it's the right fit.
If I were to tell someone how to prepare and be dressed for an interview,...
...I would really say to pick something that really exemplifies who you are,...
...and that you feel really confident in.
The one thing I consciously avoided...
...was actually my classic interview outfit that I've had for many years,...
...which is this navy blue suit,...
...and I was determined to wear anything other than that suit, basically.
So, I got dressed the way that I felt was right and that's how I got my job.